let's just jump in to this first story
we have the report here from abc news
plant spokesman says russian troops have
begun shelling europe's largest nuclear
power station in ukraine plant spokesman
says russian troops have begun shelling
it that's basically the news that's it
but we're not stopping there
we actually have this live stream um
i can't read cyrillic so i don't know
who's the person who has the live stream
up it's not us but someone has been able
to get a live stream of the plant you
can see there's some smoke uh coming out
of it the camera has moved periodically
but let me just do this let me jump to
this it seems it seems to be the name of
the plan itself so i think it might be
like oh okay so it's the actual right oh
you're right yeah yeah what's up
zapparozitzka yeah all right well there
you go so we actually have uh some
photos that appears to show uh still
grabs and video clips showing the actual
shelling you can see this happening
right now
i i would be uh i would love to have had
someone who knows the finer mechanics of
a nuclear power plant to tell us what
this could mean what could happen
because apparently they've already hit
so like have they hit all of the of the
power of the power station well there's
like really
there's lots like at any nuclear
facility that you're going to be
involved in and you know someone who's
you know as i say as a military officer
i've done you know some basic battle
damage assessment training so just like
any military facility or large-scale new
um power plant you know there's going to
be lots of outlier buildings
administrative buildings office
buildings
there's way more buildings around this
thing than the actual
nuclear reactors that have the rods in
them that have the ability to to melt
down or anything like that now that
being said
it's not a good idea to have a firefight
at a nuclear pant planet to be firing
artillery and throwing grenades and and
all the rest of that for various very
obvious reasons so this is is this uh
what is this we have this this image
here
zaporitska
but uh this is just north of uh
malitopol
and that's what just north of crimea
near the sea of azov
and so it's so it's on the denepa river
so every every nuclear plant needs a
water source right right this is your
basic nuclear power um
uh
value proposition so the same reason by
the way why most by a lot of u.s navy
ships as uh all u.s carriers and all u.s
submarines are nuclear-powered because
obviously they have
yeah you know
access to water plentiful access to
water um i was going to say though
russia has attempted
and it's you know kind of on-again
off-again to make a nuclear-powered
cruiser so actually with the capability
of essentially being able to file fire
cruise missiles yeah as this massive
nuclear-powered platform which even the
u.s doesn't do
so what's what are we doing here what's
this is this the is this just a shocking
moment it's a flash in the pan and maybe
nothing bad will happen or uh well it
seems i mean it seems this is again this
is part of russia's strategy right they
are trying to take over all the
strategic key points of ukraine and
they're what they're trying to do really
is cut the entire country of ukraine in
half using that denim river as their
essential boundary so either they're
coming down on the north towards kiev
they're coming up from the south through
uh starting obviously in crimea which
they had already annexed in 2014 coming
up north they already took the city of
croson so the next logical move for any
military procession in this was that you
would you would continue up the river
did you see that uh map from lukashenko
belarus showing the attack into moldova
though right yeah what do you think
about that
um i mean that could be a lot of things
now we already know that russia does
have some troops in that separatist
region of transit transnistria so it
could have been a reference to that i
mean the the quality of the map was hard
to kind of really make out if there was
any writing on it or anything like that
and um obviously i you know everybody
knows that you know i live with a uh i
have a live-in translator when it comes
to this part of the world my wife uh
being belarusian and uh so we weren't
able so i was asked i asked her if she
could see anything on there she said i
couldn't really see anything but i
remember the night that this all started
um
we were down in cpac and we were staying
at this place had like crappy hotel
wi-fi um nice hotel with crappy wi-fi
down in orlando and putin's up giving
his speech and she's like translating it
in real time and then i'm tweeting it
out and then zelinski's coming up giving
his response and people are all like you
know how is house posobi getting this
stuff so fast i'm like i have a
translator sitting there
that's always the most difficult thing
i've seen a lot of videos of putin's
statements and i don't know that
someone's translated it properly you
know do you trust a random person on the
internet just posting quotes
you know what i mean there was a funny
moment of that everyone watching 2000 in
the fog of war that's right funny moment
in 2007 with with condi rice when she
was meeting with medvedev remember and
she kicked the translator out of the
room because she speaks russian and she
said you're not tr like she accused the
the russian translator of purposely
american translators of like either not
purposely but she accused the american
translator of botching the translation
to a point that it was distracting her
and so she wants the translator to leave
how many times that's pretty
that's an example how many times do you
think this is happening today like over
and over and over again yeah already
there we were talking about
mistranslations in like islam and that
the word power and force also mean god
in in arabic yeah and like come on talk
about it and you listen to the msnbc
translation of the state of the union
yeah i was gonna say they don't even
translate biden properly um just an
update on as what we're seeing and the
stream is freezing now so i mean we
might be losing um
you know our ability to see what's going
on at this uh power plant but
ukraine's energy ministry and again fog
of war grain of salt all the normal you
know couching statements and uh
corollaries that we have to say but
ukraine's energy ministry is now
claiming that firefighters have been
fired at by russian troops while trying
to put out the fire i don't because
they're going directly into an active
car it's possible um
it's entirely possible yeah if you're a
firefighter and there's conflict they
don't know who you are they might fire
upon you but i just i'm i'm really not a
fan of these comic book villainy
claims that that come out from the west
and to be honest even from you know
russia oh we don't want ukraine to get
nukes or whatever or we're trying to
de-nazify putin saying you know we're
gonna have an antifa thing or whatever
that's ridiculous but but the idea you
know that we we're hearing the the
absolute comic book villainy of both
sides from both sides the propaganda is
the russians are evil and they got these
these videos of pow russian pows crying
and saying like i didn't know they were
going to make me kill women and children
or whatever and i'm like dude
don't parade around pows to me because i
don't trust them when they say that
right you've captured them their their
lives are at risk the ukrainian uh
special forces command said we're not
going to take prisoners anymore and a
lot of people were like well that's an
admission of a war crime they were like
no more capture if we do we're going to
sl i think what do they say slaughter
like pigs or something yeah but that
actually i did see some people pushing
back on that and as we were just saying
that may have been kind of a translation
thing where
the the connotation may have been more
like
you we're gonna kill you in battle so
you won't you won't be alive for us to
take prisoner right as opposed to we're
we're not going to allow you to
surrender no they they tweeted in
english something and then deleted it
yeah there was like a tweet that was so
i think that was either kiev independent
or kiev post that was that was covering
what was said but they may have been
going off of the mistranslation right
right but again i mean so here's what i
keep saying throughout all of this right
and the one thing i've instituted um
with all my team is saying i we're on a
24-hour
you know rule with all this stuff
because how many stories have come out
since the beginning of this conflict
almost it's i think one week i think
we're at the one week mark today right
um that within 24 hours have been
completely debunked right this shelling
or this pilot
or snake island right it sounds like a
hollywood script right it sounds like
you're a full movie yeah you're like
like a movie script and you're and at
first you're oh my gosh this is this i
can't believe it and then it turns out i
can't believe it but you actually can't
believe it right so
keep in mind that you know you're seeing
these situations and it's it's meant to
emotionally affect you and emotionally
hook you
and the western media by the way has
been leaps and bounds beyond anything
russia has put out in terms of their
information operations here so kind of
one little corollary i threw out there
was you know this sort of debunked all
of russiagate right because it wasn't
wasn't the predicate for russiagate the
idea that the russians were these
masters at information warfare they
dominated the global information
environment and then it turns out that
okay well here's russia in an actual
shooting war which they would really
need to have their best info ops up and
they're you know screaming about
genocide and nazis and sure you you know
we can talk about the azov battalion and
we can be very truthful about what's
going on but at the same time and yes
there is shelling in donbass yeah 100
but it's not the exact same thing that
they're alleging they got the the the
instagram hot babes
of russia coming out against uh vladimir
putin's against their own government
he's done and some of these times yeah
and some of these uh i thought i thought
was gonna do it but these instagram
models are like the daughters of
government officials
see the thing is
this is the power of influence war the
u.s controls instagram
these young women make money off
instagram and feel social acceptance
from likes when that's threatened to be
taken away from them they immediately
come out and say no no i support the
other country
that is scary like our corporations do
whatever china is yeah exactly
absolutely it's terrifying when
tick-tock controlled by china is
operating here for the exact same reason
and what will happen if china moves into
taiwan tik tok is going to light up and
all of these american tick tockers are
going to be like what taiwan is china
and china has a right in blah blah
taiwan is the republic of china
technically it is china and the ccp is
an invading force i don't know you had a
tick tock no i don't actually i think
we got banned from maybe i do have a
ticket i don't remember i don't think i
do but it's a republic of china that's
the uh the real government of china the
republic that was basically pushed onto
the island by the republic i restore the
republic i love the uh the the thing
that the west that america has exported
to the world as the awful hyperbolic
language like when sergey lavrov the
russian foreign minister is talking
about the denotification of ukraine and
they are nazis i'm like you sound like a
17 year old kid in like a high school
debate team like are we all talking on
this awful hyperbolic i'm gonna get rid
of the nazis from ukraine
it's just it's awful how someone who's
been a statesman for 60 years it sounds
like like a tick tock kid right now like
a boomer yeah that's just unbelievable
well he's got to hold on to that though
because that's now the official line
yeah no he has to it's just embarrassing
because i think we need to remember too
that you know any of these statements
now that that lavrov is making and
you're right that he's he's been known
as someone who's actually pretty highly
respected in the international community
even though you know obviously they
disagree with him on a lot that all of a
sudden he's throwing that away to you
know throw off these these little like
you know pot shot like wd wwe kind of
lines and the reason is though
that's all getting played internally
yeah right and so they're going to show
that to the russian people and they're
going to and it's it's going to play
into this new narrative and it's the
same narrative that of course biden and
all of these companies that are coming
out now and and banning russians you've
got oh think i was going to say earlier
canada
has said this canadian minister of uh
transportation has that they're holding
a charter plane in canada full of
russian nationals and they're not going
to let it go
right so the internal narrative in
russia right now is that it's the world
versus you and guess what the world is
playing right into yep thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you